Okay.
So Andy is our guest here today.
She has been for quite some time,
the director of access technology at
the National Federation of the blind.
And in this role she has worked with
top companies like Microsoft, uh,
blackboard, Ebay, apple,
Google of course, um,
to shape the way that they develop and
test their products for accessibility.
She's now at Microsoft in the
role of pm for accessibility on,
I knew I was going to
not be able to say this,
the corporate and external
legal affairs team. Um,
and she's been in that role
since 2015 she's also author,
coauthor of a book
called insuring digital
content accessibility through
policies and procedures.
And she's got a wealth of
experience and knowledge.
So I'll just bring her up to
start, start talking. Welcome Anne.
Hello. Are you buddy? Yep. Every time.
You guys are way amazing.
Hopefully I won't put you to sleep.
Well, you guys have coffee
ready? Doesn't face all right.
How could you not have coffee ready
when you are in Washington, right? Yeah,
exactly.
So every time I come to Google campus,
whether it is in Kirkland
and mountain view, um,
New York,
I always feel extremely welcoming.
I am humbled and grateful
by the hospitality that
you have extended to me for
this many, many years. My, his
history of partnering with Google,
advocating for accessibility,
being a royal pain sometimes for
you and other companies will uh,
uh, happening, you know,
go going back 10 years ago,
probably 10 years ago.
Wow. Many of you is still,
for many of you in this room
are probably not in college yet.
That amazing. Anyway, um,
in the past 10 years you have listen
to the voice of customers and I really
admire that about Google.
I have an opportunity to
witness tremendous amount
of improvement coming from
you
and your hard work.
And I think it's only right
to take time to celebrate.
And I want to go to through some of the
accessibility improvement that I've seen
happening from Google in the
past 10 years, which by the way,
even though I am working for Microsoft,
I rejoice in that.
I like accessibility improvement because
at the very heart of who I am,
I'm an accessibility
advocate and I live it every day.
And so when my peers are
successful in this arena,
I think we have the opportunity or the
obligation to celebrate your success and
every other company success
that especially those who
are willing and commit to
accessibility and willing
to do the hard work,
willing to do what it takes to
make accessibility possible.
And you may think that
partnering across the industry,
it's a rare thing, but really honestly
it must happen in accessibility.
Uh,
you and I know very well that we're
competing in power priorities every day.
I accessibility, accessibility,
priorities, let me try again.
Accessibility priorities,
uh,
often compete with other
priorities in product development.
And if the,
and I think the only way for us to gain
a foot hole in accessibility is for
industry to partner together to move
the accessibility agenda forward.
Let's face it, if Google does
it, wouldn't Microsoft do it?
Wouldn't apple do it with Facebook?
Do it in turn.
If we work in partnership with
each other across the industry,
then ultimately we'll make
our daily work much easier.
The um, accessibility improvements
that I've seen from Google.
It was a dream as of 10 years ago now,
but some of these improvements
already visible in your products,
so let's take time to
celebrate some of them,
you know, have Braille in the
various platforms of your product.
You know,
when we
came to Google,
we were,
we as in the use the users community,
especially blind user.
We're asking Google Google about Braille
and we didn't,
we weren't sure what the, we got to get
it, but the fact that we have it today,
it's something that we need
to celebrate. Uh, the Android,
oh, sorry, the Chromebook accessibility
steadily improving Google apps.
Accessibility continues to improve over
the years and then with the release of
android marshmallow and android.
Okay.
I must say the accessibility improvement
and you have done is I needed to be
commended.
I know individuals who had
die hard apple fan is now,
are now taking a look at Android,
no kid as viable options.
This is something that we
need to celebrate. You have
a tremendous leadership,
uh, team that provide
you with proper guidance.
And I've come to know many of them.
Um,
Eve Anderson,
of course,
I consider her to be a good
friend and great colleague. Uh,
I'm going to pick on you
Lewis, Anna, Laura, uh,
Premera from, um, the chrome team,
Sean laureate and Richard John will,
I'm going to leave somebody out
and they're going to be offended.
So I better stop well on the head. So, uh,
but your success here,
we need to celebrate,
but I'm sorry to say that it does
not need to be only your success,
but we need to work together again to
move the agenda forward for the whole
industry.
Because of this reason,
we are creating our products to be
accessible and usable by our customers.
Our customers are the most important,
um, individuals that were served.
We are better start listening to them.
In the recent years,
every company in the industry see the
straw procurement language inserted into
accessibility, uh, into
a procurement policy.
Our enterprise.
Customers want to know that
when they purchase our products,
they want to be reassured that when they
purchase our product and the deploy our
products and services and that everyone
will be able to use our products and
services.
Now our customers are coming from a very
diverse demographic background as you
know,
and we have the responsibility as
technology company to find ways to empower
every individual and give
them opportunities to be
the best that they can be.
I also would like to point out to you
that the need of our external customers
are not very different from the knee of
the internal colleagues with disability.
It is extremely important and I think
imperative for people or for the
technology companies to examine our
employment environment to ensure that we
have an inclusive workforce.
Microsoft taking that seriously.
I know Google has taken us seriously and
I hope more and more people are doing
this,
so now how can we
ensure that everything that
we create is accessible?
I would like to propose that we employed
three basic principles that I learned
to work very well in the past so
many years that have been an ad, uh,
advocacy for accessibility.
And by the way,
the experience that sharing with you
today I hope will prove useful at the
minimum,
at least it's thought provoking,
is the experience that I gleaned from
seeing things happening on both sides of
the camp. Uh, I think, uh, my
experience is quite unique in that,
you know,
I used to represent a solely the end
users community and now I'm working with
major industry player. So, um,
so I hope that my experience
can be useful to you.
But the three principle that I would
like to bring to this talk are the
following empathy,
engineering excellence and policy.
We must learn from our diverse pool of
our cost of our customers and colleagues
with disability when we
truly understand their needs.
That is, I believe, when we can make
the right choice on how we can innovate.
As an example,
if you have a complicated menu structures,
why not just put a
edit box,
edit feel where people can enter in the
command to search the commands name to
search for various features
in the program. So not
everybody has to go through,
uh, the, the, uh, complicated
menu structures. And this
is good for everybody,
not just the blind, but
um, everyone who you don't,
I don't quite remember where the
location of certain feature said maybe.
Okay.
So things like that seems
simple, right? But, uh,
we don't take the time to
think about it often enough.
So does accessibility design
truly make product better?
I believe yes. And I think you do too
because if you don't believe that it is,
so you probably wouldn't be here
on Monday morning at 10 o'clock.
I, you probably watched the debate. Don't
worry, I won't get into it last night.
Staying up late and now you're here.
So you must have some certain level
of commitment to accessibility,
which I'm very glad to know now
that let just not take my
word on this, right. Uh,
less examine historical record.
I believe that I have over old 250
years of data to convince you that
accessibility actually make our product
better. And I'm going to go through them.
No, just kidding. Not every, not
everything, not everything. So,
but let's just look at a three example.
If you want to know more. By the way,
I have,
I had handed my book over to Emma to be
included in Google library just for you
to use as reference
material. But let me, uh, oh,
that's good to know. Uh, let, let
me mention two or three things.
Cordy keyboard.
So the qwerty keyboard
was created by a man Oh,
in the, the 18 set, the late 17 hundreds,
uh, some type, some form of
this qwerty keyboard, uh,
to allow his blind wife to write
him letters when he went on many,
many long distance business trips.
I'm so thankful that our mode of
transportation, it has advanced.
We don't have to do a,
we don't have to use the
same motor transportation in
the 17th centuries anymore.
But nevertheless,
this keyboard in some form,
some form of this keyboard
has been with us since then.
I love the fact that accessibility
actually created out of love.
That's pretty cool. And standalone
reading machine for the blind.
So in the 1970s not the Ray Kurzweil who
now you have as part of your colleague,
I'm pretty jealous about that.
Um,
he is a beloved figure and among
the blind community in the 1970s,
he,
um,
created and invented a stand alone
reading machine for the blind.
And back then all the machine,
it's about the size of a washing machine,
I think.
Um,
and as obviously have a very
slow computing capacity.
But the groundbreaking thing about
this machine is it incorporated a three
important technologies,
speech synthesizer,
omnifont character recognition technology,
and a flatbed scanner.
Now, if you asked it, the Kurzweil,
and if you don't get a chance to meet
him or at many of you have a chance to
meet him, I would recommend it.
He's a very stimulating individual.
He would tell you flat out that this
machine was created because he met a
adopted daughter genic and the president
of the National Federation of the blind,
um, in, in the 1970 and up.
And he asked atherogenic and what kind
of problem and you want to solve for
blind people and other
children. I said, well,
we want to be able to give blind people
the ability to read print immediately,
seamlessly,
easily just as sighted people.
Well then they,
you know,
the doctor Kurzweil and then
invented the reading machine.
So look at today how individually
we use these technologies.
Speech,
synthesizer,
a omnifont character recognition
could go use it all the time.
I use it all the time. And flatbed
scanner, you scan pictures, I dunno,
probably weekly or daily and other,
uh, technology, uh,
invention that start first,
uh,
for the blind. And, uh,
it was the record player and
was invented by Thomas Edison.
And if you look at his
pattern is in my book does a,
there he invented the record player
because he wants to be able to give, uh,
the blind ability to read.
Now,
in the last century or more,
we have experienced the explosion
of a multi billion dollar industry.
Uh, I don't know how many of you
liked music, but I love music. Um,
and so record player just created,
you know,
to give the blind the ability
to read, uh, have really,
uh, morphed into supporting, uh, uh,
like I mentioned that the
multimillion dollar music industry,
which is I think is remarkable,
uh,
from this and sample it ability to
design does not only make our products
better,
but I believe accessibility is
a true source of innovation.
Again, just look at how these
types of technology change how we,
the public consume information today.
What about current example?
Do we have any all right.
I believe so. You know,
recently Facebook, um, really, uh,
invest in image recognition technology
now to describe a images on the web.
Google, Microsoft, apple provide
accessibility out of the box. Um,
and uh,
you know,
you can look at Amazon and their effort
in making [inaudible] more accessible.
This is [inaudible] good beginning
however we must do even more.
And you asked why do we want to do more?
The reason is we want to do more because
unemployment rate among people with
disability is still very, very high. And
the technology that we create can help
level the playing field for people with
disability.
If you look at the unemployment statistic
for people with disability in the
United States,
um,
just the blind demographic
have 70% unemployment rate.
The work that you do today matters a lot.
Now we friendly guys.
If we have a country that has that
kind of unemployment statistic,
the country would not survive.
But yet we have people with disabilities
all over the world combating a
unemployment rate this
high. And again, we have uh,
an opportunity to make a difference here
in the past 16 years that I have been
an at and accessibility advocate,
I learn similarly to other areas.
I'm queue up too soon.
I learned that similar similarly
to other areas of computing,
security and privacy as an example,
it's engineering excellence,
also applicable to accessibility
and accessibility design.
Without engineering excellence,
it's not only difficult to integrate
accessibility design techniques into the
development framework,
but maintaining accessibility will also
be very difficult if not impossible.
The under the industry can do more
to support our pms and engineers.
Now, how many of you are
pms? Just say I nobody.
Just one eye. How many of
you are engineers? Wow,
that's great.
I appreciate you taking the time.
I hope not too boring for you just yet.
Um,
I would like to recommend the following
items for your consideration as you are
working in Google and as a exists as the
industry press forward on accessibility
agenda. I really do think,
see whether you agree with me.
I really do think that you may not want
to admit it because you're on camera.
You know too.
I really do think that the industry should
provide engineer with better tooling.
No. Yes, there you go. Um,
and and we should talk
more about that and uh,
industry should do more to increase
the talent pipeline in accessibility
computing area by partnering with
Educational Institution to ensure
accessibility curriculum. I taught at
all level. Let me ask you something guys.
Those of you who just graduate from
college or been in college for the past 10
years, how many of you are
taught accessibility design? Wow.
You win in colleges university.
Yeah.
Nobody. I am going to take
silence as no buddy. Um,
so if, if somebody has been
taught, then please, uh,
please let me know and I'm, I'm
happy for you if you have. So, uh,
and the third thing that industry need
to do is to celebrate the achievement of
engineers who invest in accessibility and
make a difference in making accessible
products.
And finally,
companies can do more to create a
well structured mentoring program to
disseminate knowledge on
accessibility design among engineers.
And we're going to take a look
at this one by one shortly.
But I think that if we take
proper steps as an industry,
we can swiftly and more holistically,
uh,
moving sustainability agenda forward.
And isn't that our goal?
Now,
one of the biggest gap that I would like
to see the industry solve is tooling
engineers and developers need toolings
that will enable them to design
accessible websites and applications
and other products easily,
seamlessly going back as far as the
wireframe product development stage.
Don't you agree? Are
you naughty? Won't work.
Sorry guys.
Um,
today when we talk about accessibility,
automated tools,
we often think about the various
accessibility testing tool,
both pay and free.
Even though these tools are useful,
but they can only perform an audit after
website or applications are created,
accessibility design must truly
be built in and not add on it.
We started to think about accessibility
after apps and websites are created is
absolutely too late.
So what does this ideal tool look like?
Well,
in my opinion,
this idea to should have at minimum
this feature sets we should find in it a
repository of all accessible standard
controls relevant to the platform for the
engineers to use.
This will help eliminate the
need for customized controls.
I'll tell you one of the things that I,
every time I talk to developers,
I often tell them,
do not use customize controls
because if you use customize control,
you're going to have to
do tremendous amount of work to
make those controls are accessible.
But it's not always clear that
standard controls is any better.
Uh, or at least especially for
those who are new to accessibility.
So we need to make those status
control easier to discover,
provide guideline.
The two should provide guideline two
engineers on how to create accessibility,
sorry,
accessible and logical layout so that
every controller and every piece of
content in the applications
are on the website,
are properly marked up and can be accessed
with various input devices that is
not,
that are not a mouse base.
The tool should immediately alert
engineers when it detects code that blacks
accessibility property before
compiling if necessary.
The repository of this,
uh,
the tool should also contain the
repository of accessible sample code.
This is going to be
useful for engineers who
are new to accessibility
and what to learn,
how to code in an effective
matter at any given moment.
This ideal tool that I'm talking about
here should be able to provide the
developers and engineers with the ability
to simulate how a piece of code will
function with the various,
uh,
popular access technology product
that people would disability use.
The tool should be able to detect the
logical flow and order of how users use
the product to come to
complete core feature set.
And lastly,
we must provide a robust a p I n s d
k so that every developer and every
engineer's everywhere candy below in
an accessible manner. As far as I know,
we had many accessibility tools out there,
but as far as I know,
we don't have a tool that have as
comprehensive as feature set as the one I
described. And if you do
have any, please let me know.
I believe though that with
the use of AI technology,
it is possible for someone
to create such a tool.
Now here's a challenge for you.
Will Google do it first?
Hm.
We'll other player in
the industry do it first.
Now increasing the talent pipeline.
It is important as mentioned for us to
do more as an industry to partner with
educational institutions to elevate
the importance of accessibility,
design study two s an equally level
off important as cyber securities
discipline. You said, wow, really?
Do we really need to get that radical?
Yes we do.
We really do.
Accessibility need to be
viewed as a core feature set.
Many people who graduated from
colleges and university today, um,
especially if they graduated
with a degree in Cybersecurity,
uh, there are celebrated, uh, they
are recognized for their talent.
We need to do the same thing for
people who graduate from colleges and
university today. We'd great
accessibility d design knowledge,
what engineer join a firm with the
require skill set that the forum,
once the company has the obligation to
ensure that he or she have opportunities
to advance and have a
fulfilling career path.
Accessibility engineer
need to be celebrate.
And the success of the engineers who
instrumental and pms for that matter who
instrumental
in developing accessible products
need to be celebrate.
And companies need to
find ways to, to, um,
connect engineers with
individuals who is the,
who are directly benefiting from that,
the application that they created.
I think to me by putting a group of
engineers with people with disability and
listen to the end user,
uh,
on how products they're products that
they create and make it such a difference
in their lives,
the best way to motivate
each other.
And lastly,
we cannot underestimate the value of
a well structured mentoring program,
which ultimately will help facilitate
knowledge transfer among engineers.
You know, and pms for that matter.
You know, uh, there's a lot of,
hmm,
you know, for, for whatever reason, uh,
turnover among engineers and pm because
there's tremendous amount of opportunity
across the industry.
But,
but then what happened when,
when excessive and accessibility
champion leaves a company, uh,
where, where those knowledges, I, uh,
has it been preserved anywhere and I
think we should do better as an industry,
uh,
to preserve a knowledge so that engineers,
a new engineers can take advantage of
what has been done in the past if we take
this action.
I honestly feel that
engineers can flourish even
more than they do today.
But before I move on to policy,
I know that my life is enriched by your
work and the work of many engineers and
pm whom I will never
have a chance to meet.
I want to take the time
to thank you.
Thank you for the hard work that you
have put into this to empower people like
me
through your,
through the various
technology that you create.
It I'm able to stay productive
because of your hard work.
So thank you very much for that.
I just paid to you an ideal picture of
how things ought to be if the industry
worked together. But you said, wait a
minute, wait a minute, wait a minute.
We're not there yet and here I am.
I'm looking for ways to uh,
enhance my knowledge and skill today.
Is there anything that I can do or do
I have to wait until somebody else do
something?
No,
I don't think you have to wait and I
would like to recommend the following for
you to consider.
I know Cuco have a robust training
program and everybody else in the industry
should too.
And when that end and the engineers and
pm should take advantage of the training
programs offered by the
respective company. Do not.
Please do not design in the vacuum.
Always partner with accessibility subject
matters experts while you're doing
your design work. I, if you do that,
you will have less regret
in the end when possible,
and I know your time is the most
precious commodity, but when possible,
find ways to participate in the ongoing
work of the various accessibility
standard consortium,
either in person or obtain knowledge
online if you can do it in person.
This is great because it is an excellent
way to connect with other experts in
the industry
regularly conduct usability,
product usability testing even when you
feel that your product is compliant and
please conduct your product testing with
people with disability who used access
technology every day.
I know that product
testing can be very costly,
but until we get the right tooling,
we need usability testing and if
you conduct usability testing,
you gained tremendous insight from the
end user with disability that you can't
just glean from the
automated testing tool alone.
Code according to accessibility standard
and do not code according to a specific
type of access technology solution.
This is really important because if you
decided to pivot one way or the other
toward any particular
access technology solutions,
you may break your product when the next
release of that solution came out or
when and you're going to be doing
your work in vain if that a technology
solution decreases in popularity.
Finally,
let's move to policy.
Companies should really think about
established strong inclusive workforce
policy.
I know that none of that Microsoft
is benefited greatly by this.
We are as good as our people
are.
We have to make sure as an the industry
that
the customers who we serve externally
are properly represented by the diverse
pool of employees in our organization.
If we don't do that,
how can we tackle accessibility and
understand the nature of the problem
in the enough depth and breadth so
that we could solve it appropriately?
Always aim high.
I know engineers aim high,
but I am encouraging you to aim even
higher when you create a develop products.
Please use accessibility guideline as it
meant to be used as a minimum benchmark
for accessibility.
Don't ever lose sight of the end goal.
And the end goal is I'll products and
services must be accessible and usable by
everyone.
Finally,
five accessibility champions within
your organization at all level.
Guys, how many people are
here? 10, maybe two. Now,
I don't know how many of them
walk out. Um, but anyway,
that's all. Okay, well, hey weekend
too. How about that? Um, but anyhow,
um,
you can make a difference even within
a behemoth company like Google,
if you were so committed to accessibility
to begin to work together across all
level,
top down and bottom up and
everywhere else in the company.
If we take this seriously,
I think that it is possible to have an
accessible product with every release.
So I really feel strongly that we at
a cost of something great is about to
happen.
10 years ago,
accessibility was a word to avoid.
Uh, it's, it's a, um, some people said, oh
gosh, do we really have to deal with this?
I guess, suppose so, because
otherwise we, we might be in trouble.
We might be litigated against today.
Accessibility is no longer as a mandate,
but it's becoming something that people
are welcome and to becoming something
that people really want to
move forward with it. So,
but it's going to take everybody.
It's going to take the end community.
Partnering with you is going to
take the commitment from your part.
It's going to take everybody to move
accessibility forward and one day when you
grade, oh, I just want to warn
you, you're going to get there.
And when you have to use glasses,
uh,
some of you may encounter,
um,
situational disability.
You know,
those of you especially who are
really active and playing sport,
you may have to wear crutches and stuff
one day just because you break a leg or
something.
And to Kim,
you'll productive during those
time will be very, very important.
And one day you're going to look
back and said, know what you find?
Count any disability with a
permanently or temporarily.
I don't have to worry about losing my
productivity because technologies are
created to be accessible.
So I asked for your commitment
and I'm giving it to you
that I will always be an
accessibility advocate.
And I hope that I'm able to inspire
you or at least give you something,
thought provoking to go and really examine
your own commitment to accessibility.
And I'm hoping to see you and meet with
you 10 years from now and recount the
progress that I've just done
early on in this presentation.
All of the various accessibility
improvement, Ashley, you know, what,
10 or 15 years from now, we shouldn't
be talking about this topic anymore.
It should be matter of course.
So I thank you for your time
and I'll entertain annotated
question that you have.
Um, okay. So something that came to mind,
uh, during your talk, how to do
with prioritizing accessibility.
This is always a challenge for
every product in every team, um,
especially when you have
deadlines and other,
other scary things that are happening at
the same time. How, in your experience,
maybe you can give a few examples of
ways that you've been able to champion
accessibility in a,
in a tight environment like that.
Sure. Um, I can't, well, let me,
let me just do it this way.
I think we have telemetries,
uh,
on how our products are used, or at least
I hope you do. And I think you do a,
we know what core features are a four
sided and for the blind and for everybody.
And I would start there. What are
the core features in your products?
And you make that accessible.
If you really have to prioritize first,
you make that,
then those features accessible and,
and, and, and then you
go from there. It's,
I don't think it's rocket
science about this, um,
because people, uh, and,
and I don't mean to be
condescending in any way about this.
I think
everybody have the same needs.
We just access information
in a different way.
Does it help at all with
respect to a specific example?
Um,
I'll talk about a product that actually
created an accessibility community,
uh, rather than, um, uh,
current Microsoft product.
Um,
and the parallel analogy will
be a very much identical.
So we were looking at ways to create
a portable book reader for the blind,
uh, in my work with a company
named human where, I don't know,
in a 2007, 2006 or something, uh,
and we want to make that,
uh,
we'll play,
are accessible.
When we started to evaluate
what are some core features
of a digital book reader. I remember back
then, digital book reader are quite, uh,
new. Uh, and so we spent some
time looking at what, uh,
the mainstream industry is doing and
then we bring that features into,
uh,
the development.
And the result was one
of the most popular,
still is one of the most
popular stand alone,
a digital book reader for the blind called
the victor reader stream, which are,
it's one of the most exciting
project that I got a chance to,
to partner with various engineers
because we designed everything from the,
from the ground up,
and we wrestled with this priorities
every day. And you do too.
So I would say use your telemetry is
that you have available to you and make
sure those core feature sets are
accessible first. That's great.
Thanks. Cool. Oh, do you my question?
Great.
So my name is Dasha and I'm a developer
on maps. Uh, before asked me a question,
I actually want to turn to the
audience a lot of the things and um,
and talked about actually
we have internally.
So in order for your product to shape him,
you must pass to given gardening and
we have a guard discussion this week,
so you're welcome to join us for that.
We also have classes running this
week because it is a stability week.
So educate yourself.
There's an Ios and android in a design
class happening this week, so you're very,
very welcome to come.
And my question is actually around Ui.
When you were describing your
perfect tool or our SDK,
um,
it made me wonder that we don't even
have that for regular stuff. I mean,
there is not one place where you can build
the Ui depending on what platform you
are, you're stuck with that platforms.
Um, good and bad points, right?
So I think,
uh,
I don't know if that will ever happen
to have one place where you can build Ui
and works on everything. Right? Right.
Now you build Ui for this platform and
then for that platform then for that
platform,
mostly because otherwise
you can't leverage the best
parts of a given platform.
Um, what do you think about that? Well,
we must work with what we
have so far, right? I mean,
I honestly feel that if
I have this magic tool,
they can split code out in all platforms
and ensure accessibility of everything
everywhere at the same time. That
would be best. But when, when we,
now we don't, so let me give you
an example. In android platform
you really
need to think hard about how people
with disability use technologies.
So what are an important
characteristic of attributes?
Uh,
oh, feature sets that are, uh,
to, to them, uh, as an example,
I don't know, this is, I think this is
correct. Uh, last I checked is correct.
So if it's not correct, I want
you to correct me. Uh, Andrew,
I know get tremendous amount
of accessibility improvement.
But currently if you develop
mmm,
a webpage,
a correctly,
uh,
with proper table mock
ups, it in html, uh,
you cannot,
you can still not use and android no
good with top back to take advantage of
that mockup.
So you still have to traverse table,
cell by cell and you know how
tedious that think get. So
if you understand that people
with disability want to
traverse table in the way
that you do go column by column skip
columns and we need to skip roles and we
must then in uh,
our API around development a framework,
we should give the ability for the
APP developers to do just that.
That's what I meant when I
say we really need to, uh,
consider the needs of customers even,
uh,
throughout the designing
process. Does it help? Yeah.
So rather than a two, a one to
one, what I'm hearing you say,
each platform should do better,
should care more.
Well, [inaudible] tools
is important, right?
So if you provide necessary a
tutorial in the tool and said,
hey,
guess what developers now you can take
advantage of table mock ups and Itch to
Mellon. Here's how you do, here's
how you do your development. Uh, it,
it's,
if the tool has that feature set that
will give guidance to engineers and
developers, that would be even
better. I don't remember that. A,
a t access technology simulations
that I was talking about. Uh,
I don't think anybody has it,
but if you were to create, uh,
a content and then you
render it into an html table,
you can immediately see what the behavior
of navigating that table with talk back
and Braille back and such like right
there in the tool. I know I'm dreaming,
but I really think it can happen.
I really do.
Somebody somewhere is going to make this.
Thank you.
I'm Wilson
working or the, uh, uh, enterprise,
uh, how fronted. So like, um,
we've been testing our products with the
various degree readers, like, you know,
like [inaudible] to be more like the
primary ones. And then I'm surprised.
I'm just kidding. And then, um,
and then we also, we also use a,
a voiceover and then lead a NBDA
yeah. To test it. Uh, but, uh,
is there any like effort, uh, you know,
put into standardize all of
these screen reader is still,
so there was less surprised that we,
we turn to another screen reader and
behave totally differently. For example,
voiceover, it was like, you know,
there are a lot of cases that I just,
it just doesn't work.
There's a lot of nuances.
I don't know all the concentrate efforts.
Yeah.
Uh, it, it needs to happen.
And then one of the things that we can
do is code according to sensibilities
that if everybody does that,
and I think we can unify a,
some of the different, uh, you know,
the unified the differences
and make it, uh, less so.
A M I a t a I know when to under
compensated and overcompensating for worth
weapons,
disability or any accessibility standard
that makes it very difficult for
developer to develop.
Now I also understand the 80 manufacturers
predicament though they need to serve
customers.
So here again,
partnership between you and a t,
uh,
solution providers, whether it would
be your peers, uh, Microsoft, uh,
apple. I'll even bode potty
a t. It needs to happen
more and I'm,
I would love to hear your thought
on how we can bring this about too.
This is not just my conversation to you.
This is a bi directional conversation.
So you have some ideas. Uh,
Anna, how to get in touch,
knows how to get in touch with me.
Please let me know.
Okay.
I'm being kicked out. I think we are
actually been kicked up. Thank you, Anne,
for coming.
A wonderful Todd.